[Musik]
meine Lieben Zuschauer eines wird immer
mehr Menschen klar so gut wie alle
Weltregionen Steuern auf ein Zeitalter
der Kriege zu immer mehr Potentaten
erheben Ansprüche auf andere Länder und
schärfen ihre Schwerter um sie durch
Krieg an sich zu reißen 6 dezember 2023
Konflikt in Guyana annextion nach
Methode Putin jetzt droht Krieg in
Südamerika uela will zwei Drittel seines
Nachbarlandes Guyana annektieren ein
Referendum soll die Begründung für den
Einmarsch liefern die Gelegenheit hält
Karakas für günstig die USA sind von den
Kriegen in Gaza und der Ukraine
abgelenkt und Putin hat den perfekten
Ablaufplan geliefert tja wer behauptet
hat dass es in knallharten Diktaturen
nie Wahlen gebe lag am ersten Advent
dieses Jahres total falsch wenn es ihnen
nämlich in den Kram passt lassen
Tyrannen ihre Wähler sehr gerne an den
Wahlurnen antreten und ihr fragt euch VI
vielleicht wieso sollte uns das alles
überhaupt interessieren Südamerika ist
weit weg nun wie wir euch bereits in
einem früheren Video angedeutet haben
und wie wir in einem späteren Video noch
ausführlich erklären werden ist
Südamerika mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit
der Schlüssel für Europa um der
Energieabhängigkeit von Russland zu
entkommen der lateinamerikanische
Kontinent ist der Schlüssel um die
Ölpreise weltweit wieder sinken zu
lassen und bei Venezuela handelt es sich
um nichts Geringeres als das Land mit
den größten Erdölvorkommen der Welt ich
weiß klingt unglaublich aber es stimmt
doch leider werden diese Ölvorkommen
kaum erschlossen da die dortige Diktatur
die Energieindustrie total
heruntergewirtschaftet hat und außerdem
hat sie das Land auch in eine
internationale Isolation getrieben aber
das ist noch nicht alles der Grund für
den jetzigen Konflikt mit Guyana ist
nämlich ausgerechnet auch das
Erdöl aber eines nach dem anderen am 3
Dezember waren nämlich die venezelaner
obwohl sie ihre Regierung immer noch
nicht freiwählen können dazu aufgerufen
in einem Referendum über die annextion
von
qubagyana
abzustimmen Venezuela führt seit mehr
als 100 Jahren einen Territorialstreit
mit Guyana und das kleine Nachbarland
hat in den letzten Jahren große
Ölvorkommen entdeckt es geht um die
Souveränität von
159542 quadratkilm was sage und schreibe
74,21% des guyanischen Territorium
entspricht und um ihren Standpunkt zu
untermauern hat die venezolanische
Regierung ein Referendum organisiert das
Ergebnis war natürlich vorhersehbar 90%
der Wähler unterstützten das Vorhaben
dass die schastische Regierung nun
durchboxen will es geht um nichts
Geringeres als die annextion von Guyana
esequiba aber ich meine was hätten wir
erwarten sollen Maduro wird kaum ein
Referendum einberufen um es zu verlieren
tatsache ist dass die schastische
Regierung während der letzten Monate
eine Eskalation in dieser Frage herbei
geführt hat wie es sie schon lange nicht
mehr gegeben hat und nehmt bitte zur
Kenntnis dass wir hier nicht von einem
juristischen Streit oder ähnlichen
sprechen sondern von einem echten Schlag
auf die Kriegstrommeln 13 November 2023
Maduro erhebt erneut venezolanischen
Hoheitsanspruch über Guyana
quiba 23 November 2023 lula will einen
Krieg zwischen Venezuela und Guyana
vermeiden und schickt ein Vertrauensmann
als
Vermittler 7 dezember 2023 sich
Brasilien verlegt Truppen an die Grenze
zu Venezuela die Maßnahmen geben in der
gesamten Region Anlass zur Sorge während
Guyana seine Truppen in höchste
Alarmbereitschaft hält hat die
brasilianische Armee erklärt dass sie
mehr Soldaten in die Grenzstadt
boaavista die Hauptstadt des
Bundesstaates Roraima verlegt und mehr
bewaffnete Fahrzeuge heranschafft ein
militärischer Einmarsch Venezuelas würde
allerdings eine logistische
Herausforderung darstellen da
venezolanische Soldaten aufgrund des
schwierigen Geländes brasilianisches
Territorium durchqueren müssten um in
den
Qubo einzudringen so ist das nun mal der
Staatsapparat hat mit Plakaten Konzerten
Merchandising militärkundgebungen und
unaufhörlicher Werbung in den sozialen
Medien für die Abstimmung
geworden und das Ergebnis war dann auch
überragend nach Angaben der Regierung
beteiligten sich etwas mehr als 10
Millionen Venezolaner also etwa 50% der
Wahlberechtigten und von ihnen stimmten
mehr als 90% für den Gebietsanspruch der
Regierung auf den
Vibo dennoch kann die Realität ganz
anders aussehen denn die Zahl der Wähler
ist eigentlich kaum zu glauben es ist
sehr wahrscheinlich dass entgegen den
Behauptung des Regimes nur ein Bruchteil
der 10 Millionen Wähler tatsächlich an
der Wahl teilgenommen
hat aber das ist eben Venezuela und
jetzt hat das schavstische Regime einen
neuen Joker im Erbel aber vor allem
werfen die Spannungen in den Beziehungen
zwischen Guyana und Venezuela einige
Fragen auf was genau hat das
schavwiistische Regime jetzt eigentlich
mit dem Abstimmungsergebnis vor warum
ist das Interesse an diesem Thema auf
einmal so so groß wie wahrscheinlich ist
es dass im sqbo tatsächlich ein
bewaffneter Konflikt ausbrechen könnte
heute werden wir all diese Fragen
natürlich beantworten und zwar gleich
nachdem wir uns bei dem Sponsor bedankt
haben der dieses Video erst möglich
gemacht hat das heutige Video hat
übrigens unser treuer Sponsor surfshark
möglich gemacht und deswegen müssen wir
das heißt meine weihnachtskatze Angie
und ich euch unbedingt noch sein
besonderes Weihnachtsangebot vorstellen
denn solltet ihr noch kein VPN haben ist
dies nur die einmalige Gelegenheit es so
günstig wie noch nie zu be kommen wusst
ihr z.B dass viele Firmen wie Airlines
ganz unterschiedliche Preise anbieten
können je nachdem von welchem Land aus
man bestellt bzw sein Ticket Bucht aber
zum Glück kann man solche
diskriminierungsversuche mit Hilfe als
VPNs überlisten und dann richtig Geld
sparen surfsar VPN ist dabei ein
wirklich empfehlenswertes und sicheres
VPN welches z.B keiner lei
Verbindungsdaten mitlckt ein Virtual
Private Network VPN ist aber nicht nur
zum Geld sparen geeignet es kann ein
auch vor so mancher größeren
gefahrschützen die ih jetzt lauert
natürlich muss man nach wie vor Umsicht
walten lassen und und wissen was man tut
aber es stellt hierf ein Werkzeug mit
gleich mehreren Vorteilen da zum ein
erschwert es in Kombination mit anderen
Vorkehrungen eure Aktion im letz nachzu
verfolgen und abzuhören mit Hilfe
verschiedener Sicherheitsfeatures könnt
ihr so eure Anonymität im N erhöhen z.B
mit dem integrierten kenwb das alle
unerwünschen Cookies und Pop-ups blockt
weiterer Vorteil ein VP ist dass ihr so
tun könnt als wäret ihr an einem anderen
Ort so könnt ihr z.B Websites und
Internetdienste zugreifen in dem Land
den ihr gerade seid nicht verfühgbar
wäre ob daheim oder auf Reisen damit
schlagt i Zensur geoblocking ein
Schnippchen Netflix und andere
Streamingdienste die ihre Inhalte nur in
den USA Anbieten von Europa ausnutzen
oder deutsches internetfsehen im Ausland
gucken mit surf kein Problem aber das
ist noch lange nicht alles W nur einem
sur Konto könnt wirklich alle eure
Endgeräte im VPN registrieren Handys
Notebooks oder sogar euren smartvone so
und wenn ihr den Rabattcode politikde
angeht bekommt ihr von surfsark im
Rahmen des weihnachtsspecials auch noch
zusätzliche se Monate gratis dazu den
Link zu diesem Angebot findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video na
was sagst du
dazu also nichts wie los besorgt euch
surfshark und surft ab jetzt sicher und
ohne diskriminiert zu werden im
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Internet um zu verstehen wie und wann
dieser Konflikt entstanden ist müssen
wir in die Kolonialzeit zurückkehren
genauer gesagt in die Zeit als Guyana
unter der Kontrolle des britischen
Empires und Venezuela unter der
Kontrolle des spanischen Empires stand
Guyana esekba war Teil des
generalalkapitinats von Venezuela einem
sp Herrschaftsgebiet das 1777 von Karl
dei gegründet wurde doch die ersten
Kolonisten die das Gebiet besiedelten
waren keine Britten sondern Niederländer
ganz genau es waren die Niederländer die
in Ermangelung einer wirksamen Kontrolle
durch Madrid die ersten nichtpanischen
Kolonien in der Region
gründeten aber nach einer Reihe von
Kriegen und zusammenstößel verloren die
stark geschwächten Niederländer die
Kontrolle über ihre Siedlungen und die
Briten wurden
1796 de facto die her her kurz darauf
wurden durch den angl-olländischen
Vertrag von 1814 und den Wiener Kongress
von 1815 die Kolonien esbo Demerara und
berbis offiziell an Großbritannien
abgetreten und so entstand britisch
Guyana das im Westen an das
neugegründete Venezuela grenzte außerdem
erlangte Karakas gleichzeitig seine
Unabhängigkeit von Spanien und das
Problem war dass die Grenzen zwischen
den beiden Territorien überhaupt nicht
klar waren deshalb beauftragte die Royal
geographical soci die 1841 den deutschen
Naturforscher Robert Hermann Schomburg
damit die Grenzen von britisch Guyana zu
Venezuela im Westen und zu
Niederländisch Guyana dem heutigen
Surinam im Osten zu ziehen diese Studie
führte zur Festlegung der sogenannten
schomburglinie eine Grenze die britisch
Guiana effektiv 80.000 quadrkm zusprach
vor der Festlegung dieser Linie war der
quiboluss die natürliche Grenze zwischen
den beiden Territorien
gewesen und genau dieser Abschnitt
zwischen dem quiboluss und der
schomburglinie hat heute politische und
sogar militärische Spannungen zwischen
Georgetown und carakas ausgelöst die
Frage ist also warum war es nie möglich
eine Lösung zu finden ist es in den 170
Jahren wirklich nie gelungen die
Situation in der Region zu klären auf
welcher Grundlage erhebt der schavismo
jetzt einen solch aggressiven Anspruch
um das zu verstehen müssen wir ein
bisschen tiefer in den Geschichtsbüchern
Graben also auf
geht's von juristischen fallstrecken zum
Kriegsszenario nach der Besiegelung der
Unabhängigkeit im Jahr 1821 und dem Tod
von Simon bolivaro um 1830 geriet
Venezuela in eine Spirale der internen
Gewalt mehrere lokale cudios versuchten
die Kontrolle über das Land zu
übernehmen und ausgerechnet genau zu
dieser Zeit wurde die schrumburglinie
gezogen so dass als sich die Lage in
Karakas beruhigte die britische Präsenz
westlich des esquibo bereits eine
Tatsache war die normative Macht des
Faktischen um 1880 begann der damalige
venezolanische Präsident Antonio Guzman
Blanco die britische Einmischung auf
internationale Ebene anzubringern das
ging seit dass das Thema
1895 sogar auf die Tagesordnung des
Weißen Hauses gesetzt wurde der Streit
hat ein solches Stadium erreicht dass es
den USA nun obliegt Maßnahmen zu
ergreifen um mit hinreichender
Sicherheit zu ihrer Rechtfertigung zu
bestimmen welches die wahre
Trennungslinie zwischen der Republik
Venezuela und britisch Guyana ist
Präsident Grover am 17 dezember 1895 die
Botschaft des amerikanischen Präsidenten
Zwang London dazu einen internationalen
schiedspruch zu akzeptieren und im
februar 1897 einigten sich Venezuela die
USA und Großbritannien auf die
Durchführung eines Gerichtsverfahrens
das den Territorialstreit ein für alle
Mal beilegen sollte das Wort Einigung
ist allerdings nicht ganz das passendste
Wort um die venezolanische Position zu
beschreiben warum ich die Sage nun weil
eine der Regeln auf die sich Washington
und London geeinigt haben vorsah
Venezuela aus dem Schiedsgericht
auszuschließen während die Verteidigung
des südamerikanischen Landes in dem
Prozess in den Händen amerikanischer
Anwälte liegen sollte und auf diese
Weise war Karakas bei dem ganzen
Gerichtsverfahren das 1899 in Paris
stattfand nur ein Zuschauer es konnte
als Partei noch nicht mal angehört
werden das Tribunal das sich aus zwei
Britten zwei Amerikanern und einem
Russen als neutralen Richter
zusammensetzte entschied dass die
schomburglinie tatsächlich die Grenze
zwischen Venezuela und Guyana bildete
und damit die britische Herrschaft
westlich des esquibolusses legitimierte
und Venezuela bekam als Trostpflaster
die Hoheit über die Mündung des
orinokousses dabei handelt es sich zwar
um eine strategische entklave aber sie
ist wesentlich unbedeutender als der
ursprüngliche venezolanische Anspruch
die Frage ist also wie dieses
Gerichtsurteil gerechtfertigt
war nun wie ihr seht ist das 100 Jahre
später immer noch nicht ganz klar die
Begründung des Urteils wurde nie
veröffentlicht und deshalb betrachtet
Venezuela die britische Besatzung
seither als Usurpation später während
der 1950er Jahre erlebte Venezuela ein
bedeutendes Wirtschaftswachstum unter
der Diktatur von Marcos Perz Jimenes und
dieser machte Jahre nach seinem Sturz
öffentlich dass das südamerikanische
Land seit Jahrzehnten Pläne zur
militärischen Rückeroberung des Gebiets
desibo
schmiedete
wir waren dabei Maßnahmen zu entwickeln
die meiner Meinung nach auf zwei Dinge
hinausliefen entweder würde britisch
Guyana zu dieser Zeit mit einem
Sonderstatus aners venezolanische
Territorium angegliedert oder wir hätten
das Gebiet des
Qubo gewaltsam zurückgewinnen
müssen doch dabei blieb es nicht 1962
begann Venezuela vor den Vereinten
Nationen zu fordern dass der
schiedspruch von 1899 für null und
nichtig erklärt werden soll te weil es
den Verdacht hegte dass der Beschluss
die britischen Interessen begünstigen
sollte und daraufhin einigten sich
1966 sowohl Venezuela als auch
Großbritannien darauf einen neuen
Mechanismus zu finden der den Pariser
schießspruch ersetzen sollte und das
Problem war dass dies nur ein paar
Wochen vor der Anerkennung der
Unabhängigkeit Guyanas durch London
geschah von diesem Moment an mussten die
Gespräche also zwischen carakas und
Georgetown stattfinden und es überrascht
nicht dass die neue Regierung Guyanas
nichts mehr mit der Angelegenheit zu tun
haben wollte und das obwohl die
Vereinbarung zwischen London und carakas
ein Zeitraum von maximal vier Jahren
vorsah ind dem die Parteien eine
Einigung erzielen konnten am Ende kam
die ganze Angelegenheit ins Stocken mit
gelegentlichen militärischen
Auseinandersetzungen
dazwischen aber die Wahrheit ist nun mal
dass dieses Thema nach und nach in den
Hintergrund getreten ist bis tja bis
ncolas madoro es jetzt wieder auf den
Tisch geschmettert hat wie die meisten
von euch wissen ist madoro der einzige
Anführer der sogenannten bolivarischen
Revolution aber er ist weder ihr
Ideologe noch derjenige der sie begonnen
hat und deshalb ist eine wichtige Frage
die wir uns an dieser Stelle stellen
müssen die folgende wie war eigentlich
das Verhältnis der bolivarischen
Revolution zu diesem Territorialstreit
inwi weit hat dieses Thema den Anführer
der Revolution Kommandant der Chis
beschäftigt was war sein Standpunkt nun
schnallt Euch gut an denn ich glaube
dass es hier eine Menge Überraschung für
euch geben
[Musik]
wird
Chavez und Guyana die Flitterwochen die
keine
waren die Machtübernahme von Hugo chavz
markierte einen echten Wendepunkt in der
Geschichte Venezuelas im Jahr 1998 rief
er die bolivarische Revolution ins Leben
die eine komplette Umgestaltung des
politischen Systems Venezuelas
beinhaltete und wisst ihr was trotz
seines bekannten antiimperialistischen
und antiwestlichen Diskurses hat Hugo
chz von Beginn seiner Regierung an
versucht sich mit seinem ruanischen
Nachbaren zu verbrüdern es ist ein
Gefühl der Brüderlichkeit gegenüber
Guyana entstanden dass wir verstärken
wollen und ich muss euch sagen dass ich
weiterhin die Landkarten von Guyana
studiere aber nicht um Fallschirmjäger
oder Panzer in den Krieg zu schicken
sondern um zu sehen wo die Autobahn
zwischen Venezuela und Georgetown
verlaufen wird oder um zu sehen wo wir
gemeinsame Entwicklungsprojekte fördern
können hugu chavz ehemaliger Präsident
von Venezuela am 25 Februar 2004
tatsächlich war Petro karibe ein 2005
gegründetes Bündnis das es karibischen
Ländern ermöglicht wenezolanisches Öl zu
Vorzugsbedingungen zu kaufen eines der
wichtigsten Instrumente der
internationalen Politik des Sozialismus
des 21 jahrhunderts und wisst ihr was
Guyana war eines der ersten Länder das
sich dieser Initiative anschloss 23
Januar 2007
kohlenwasserstoffliefervertrag mit
Guyana unterzeichnet das Abkommen das im
Rahmen des petrocaribe Energy
Corporation agreement unterzeichnet
wurde ermöglicht es dem Nachbarland je
nach Bedarf Benzin Diesel Kerosin Heizöl
und Asphalt zu erhalten die vereinbarte
lief entspricht 50% des täglichen
Verbrauchs des Landes wie ihr seht
geriete Georgetown so in eine starke
Abhängigkeit von Kakas die der
venezolanischen Regierung enormen
Einfluss verschaffte der Bericht der
Zentralbank von Guyana aus dem Jahr 2009
verzeichnete Schulden in Höhe von 143
Millionen USDollar mit Venezuela was
damals 15% der staatlichen
Auslandsschulden entsprach und es wurde
erwartet dass ich die Schulden bis 2010
auf etwa 180 Millionen US-Dollar
belaufen würden aber trotz allem wurde
die sekbo Frage nie zur Diskussion
ell tatsächlich behandelte Chaves Guyana
so als sein beide Lände Opfer des
angloamerikanischen
Imperialismus ich erinnere mich dass
mein erster Kontakt mit Guyana aus
Kriegsplänen bestand als Venezuela in
ein subimperium verwandelt worden war
sie setzten uns vor vielen Jahren in den
Kopf dass ihr unsere Feinde seid aber
ihr und wir wir sind
Brüder und viele kritisierten ih damals
dafür für dass Venezuela eine
historische Chance verpassen würde
seinen langjährigen Gebietsanspruch zu
lösen und diese Kritik nahm zu als
Guyana begann nach Öl zu suchen 6 juni
2012 Ölförderung in Guyana entfacht
erneut Streit mit Venezuela die
Opposition warf der Regierung am
Mittwoch vor die ölexploration Guyanas
in einer von Venezuela beanspruchten
Grenzregion zu ignorieren und an diesem
Punkt stellt sich die große Frage warum
hogo chavz nichts unternommen hat um den
quibo zurückzu erobern nun die Sache war
die dass sich der shavismo vor allem auf
seine politische Konfrontation mit
Kolumbien konzentrieren
[Musik]
musste tatsächlich wagte es Chaves 2009
vor der Einrichtung von usstüzpunkten
auf kolumbianischem Gebiet anzudeuten
dass dies einen Krieg in der Region
auslösen
könnte ich erfülle meine moralische
Pflicht als Staatsoberhaupt Präsident
Venezuelas und Soldat und warne dass die
Winde des Krieges zu Wehen
beginnen deshalb versuchte Chaves die
nichtsozialistischen Länder der Region
nach und nach zu isolieren und um das zu
erreichen versuchte er so etwas wie der
schger der Lied der Karibik zu werden
und genau das hat es Guyana ermöglicht
vom venezolanischen Ölgeschäft zu
profitieren während Karakas eine
historische Konfrontation auf Eis gelegt
hat ironischerweise wurde das
venezolanische Außenministerium während
dieser gesamten Phase von keinem
geringeren als ncolos madoro geleitet
der natürlich voll und ganz auf die
Strategie seines Chefs ausgerichtet war
und genau aus diesem Grund wurde das
Thema
quibo erst dann wieder relevant als 2013
nach dem Tod von Chaves zahlreiche
Ölfirmen begannen die Existenz von
Ölvorkommen im Kontinentalschelf des
Guyana esek via zu bestätigen aber trotz
alldem kam Maduro nicht über einfache
Proteste hinaus die nur von geringer
Bedeutung
waren ja bis zur zweiten Hälfte des
Jahres 2023 als plötzlich eine Art
nationalistischer Eifer in der
bolivarischen Regierung ausbrach die
Frage ist also warum gerade jetzt und
was hat der chavismo davon diese
Kontroverse wieder aufleben zu lassen
lasst uns das noch mal genau unter die
Lupe
[Musik]
neen Spiel mit dem Feuer
übrigens falls ihr es noch nicht gewusst
haben solltet shavismo ist die in
Venezuela propagierte Ideologie vom
Sozialismus des 21 jahrhunderts und das
Interesse des chavismo an einer
Wiederaufnahme des Streits mit ist
voller Ungereimtheiten und Widersprüche
ein Beispiel dafür sind die Fragen des
Referendums an sich die Bevölkerung
wurde darin mit fünf komplexen
Formulierungen konfrontiert aber zwei
von ihnen sind besonders
besorgniserregend stimmt ihr mit der
historischen Position Venezuelas überein
die Zuständigkeit des Internationalen
Gerichtshofs für die Lösung des
territorialstreits mit Guyana esquiba
nicht anzuerkennen seid ihr mit der
Gründung des Staates Guyana esquiba und
der Entwicklung eines beschleunigten
Plans für die integrale Betreuung der
derzeitigen und zukünftigen Bevölkerung
dieses Territoriums einverstanden der
unter anderem die Verleihung der
venezolanischen Staatsbürgerschaft und
von Personalausweisen in Übereinstimmung
mit dem Genfer Abkommen und dem
Völkerrecht vorsieht s dass dieser Staat
in die Karte des venezelanischen
Territoriums aufgenommen wird diese
beiden Fragen geben dem venezolanischen
Staat ein hochriskantes volksmandat
erstens versperrt die Missachtung des
Internationalen Gerichtshofs jede
diplomatische Lösung des Konflikts und
dann kommt gleich das zweite Problem
wenn es keine diplomatische Lösung was
bleibt dann übrig aber wartet das ist
noch nicht
alles Venezuela erwgt die territoriale
Annektion des quibo was wenig
überraschend nur durch den Einsatz von
Gewalt geschehen
könnte wir werden unsere Rechte über das
abtr Guana in allen Bereichen
verteidigen ohne in Provokation zu
verfallen und ohne auf die kriegstrommel
zu hören die der Präsident von Guyana
heute geschlagen
hat GU schrillen die Alarmglocken
schließlich geht es um ganze 74% des
staatsterritoriums und den größten Teil
der Ölproduktion die immer weiter wächst
14 November 2023 Guyana sagt von dem
Internationalen Gerichtshof dass das
Referendum in Venezuela über die
umstrittene Region eine existenzielle
Bedrohung darstellt für die guyaner geht
es also um viel mehr als nur einfach
Land seitdem die Erdölförderung in
Guyana 2015 angelaufen ist erlebt das
Land ein fast exponentielles Wachstum
sass es in wenigen Jahren das reichste
Land Südamerika sein könnte aber Moment
mal liebe visualpolitik Zuschauer lassen
wir uns nicht täuschen ist es wirklich
möglich dass es bei all diesen
nationalistischen Tricksereien um den
quibo geht im Prinzip ist das nämlich
schwer zu glauben denn die Widersprüche
liegen klar auf der
Hand im Jahr 2015 in den Guyana eine
kriegerische Position des Hasses gegen
die bolivarische Republik Venezuela
einnimmt paktiert Guyana mit aon mobile
und dem südkommando der usstitkräfte
wie ihr sehen könnt hat Nicolas Maduro
selbst gesagt dass Guyana seine Haltung
2015 geändert habe warum haben Sie denn
8 Jahre lang gewartet um so energisch zu
protestieren wenn dieses Gebiet für den
chavismo so interessant ist warum haben
sie dann nicht schon früher versucht es
zurückzuerobern als die Bedingungen
dafür noch besser waren nun passt gut
auf denn die Wahrheit ist dass hier
etwas verdammt faul
ist bereit jeden zu bestrafen der es
wagt einen Quadratmeter argentinisches
Territorium anzurühren wenn sie kommen
wollen sollen sie kommen wir werden uns
wehren was ihr gerade gesehen habt ist
argentinische Diktator Leopoldo
Fortunato galtieri der in der 1
Aprilwoche 1982 vor Tausenden von
Argentiniern die Rückgewinnung der
malwinen feierte heute wissen wir dass
die Entscheidung diese Inseln zu
besetzen die unter britische
Souveränität standen viel mit dem Legi
nationsverlust der argentinischen
Diktatur zu tun hatte sagen wir einfach
dass die Sache mit der territorialen
Annexion nur ein Trick war um
politisches Kapital und
gesellschaftliche Unterstützung für den
Verbleib an der Macht zu gewinnen und
das Ergebnis war eine absolute
[Musik]
Katastrophe die brittenen schickten eine
Kampftruppe die die Argentinier Vertrieb
und den Sturz der argentinischen
Diktatur beschleunigte die Frage ist
also ob der chavismo tatsächlich eine
iche Situation anstrebt gut in der
Theorie gibt es mehrere Unterschiede zu
damals erstens ist Guyana kein
britisches Territorium sondern eine
unabhängige Nation so dass in den
Konflikt keine Militärmacht verwickelt
wäre zweitens in einem möglichen
militärischen Konflikt ist das
kräftegefälle enorm Venezuela verfügt
über 137 000 Soldaten zu Lande zu Wasser
und in der Luft während guyal
Streitkräfte nur etwa 5000 Mann zählen
also trotz der offensichtlichen
operativen Einschränkung der
venezolanischen Streitkräfte wäre der
Ausgang eines kriegerischen Wettbewerbs
für Georgetown einfach unumkehrbar und
obwohl die Umstände nicht dieselben sind
könnte das Ziel des schavismo dasselbe
sein wie das der argentinischen
militärunter man will eine demokratische
Öffnung des Landes um jeden Preis
verhindern auch um den Preis eines
militärischen Konflikts bei dem es um
die Verherrlichung einer
nationalistischen Sache geht vergesst
bitte nicht dass sowohl die
venezolanische Opposition als auch die
USA mit dem Maduro Regime über saubere
Wahlen im Jahr 2024 verhandeln was dann
höchstwahrscheinlich einen Machtverlust
des Regimes bedeuten würde deswegen
glauben viele Analysten dass die
Eskalation mit Guyana nur eine
Rechtfertigung darstellen soll für ein
Ausnahmezustand oder interne Unruhen um
den Wahlprozess einzufrieren manche
glauben auch dass das Vergangene
Referendum ein Mittel war um die
schavistische wahlmaschinerie zu
schmieren und die Änderungen der
elektronischen Abstimmung zu testen mit
denen der schavismo versuchen würde sich
an der Macht zu
[Musik]
halten und im schlimmsten Fall könnten
die Spannungen mit Guyana Kakas einen
neuen Joker in den Verhandlungen mit
Washington liefern aber wenn eines klar
ist dann dass es in dieser ganzen
Geschichte einen Akteur gibt der für den
weiteren Verlauf der Ereignisse
entscheidend sein wird die Rede ist
natürlich von den venezolanischen
Streitkräften der Punkt ist nämlich dass
auch nur ein begrenzter Krieg oder sogar
ein Invasionsversuch den Einfluss des
Militärs in der aktuellen bolivarischen
Regierung weiter stärken
würde ich bin lossen euch aufzufordern
wählen zu gehen dies ist vorerst kein
bewaffneter Krieg es ist kein
bewaffneter
Krieg im Moment hat das militärische
Oberkommando sein Engagement in der
Frage des SBO demonstriert aber die
Frage ist ob es wirklich dazu bereit
wäre sich in einen bewaffneten Konflikt
zu stürzen nur um ein politisches
Projekt am Leben zu erhalten das
momentan auseinanderfällt okay
vielleicht denkt das Militär dass eine
militärische Intervention nur von kurzer
Dauer sein würde weil Guyana sich nicht
selbst verteidigen könnte allerdings ist
es wahrscheinlich dass der Konflikt auf
regionaler oder sogar internationaler
Ebene eskalieren könnte Laura Richardson
general in der US-Armee und
befehlshaberin des US southern command
wird Guyana vom 25 bis 27 juli besuchen
um den Streitkräften Guyanas der
US-Botschaft und führenden Vertretern
der karibischen Gemeinschaft karikom
über die Verteidigungsbereitschaft der
USA mit Guyana und den caricom Partnern
zu sprechen 24 November 2023 gujanischer
vizepr prsident US verteidigungsbeamte
besuchen Guyana im Streit mit Venezuela
die Zusammenarbeit zwischen Georgetown
und Washington im Verteidigungsbereich
hat in diesem Jahr erheblich zugenommen
und was meint ihr mag damit eventuell
die Tatsache etwas zu tun haben dass
dieses Land zu einer großen ölmacht wird
die von Exon mobile angeführt wird
obwohl Guyana einer venezolanischen
Invasion allein nicht standhalten könnte
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht
auszuschließen dass eine internationale
Koalition dem Land zur Hilfe kommt und
trotz all dem scheint madoro nun bereit
zu sein eine sehr besorgniserregende
rote Linie zu überschreiten ein
militärisches Scharmützel in einer
Region zu provozieren die vom Krieg
bisher verschont geblieben war 5
dezember 2023 Venezuela bekräftigt
Anspruch auf Teil von Guyana es solle
ein venezolanische Bundesstaat Guyana
quiva geschaffen und ölförderlizenzen
nach venezolanischem recht für die
Region vergeben werden teilte der
Staatschef nach einem Fernsehbericht am
Dienstag bei einer Regierungssitzung mit
zudem zeigte er eine neue Landkarte für
die Schulen des südamerikanischen Landes
auf der der Teil des Nachbarlandes
Guyana als 24 venezolanischer
Bundesstaat ausgewiesen ist zumindest
hier im visualpolitikteam sind wir der
Meinung dass dies nicht so weiter als
ein neuer Vorwand ist um seine
Verhandlungsposition zu verbessern und
vor allem einen näherboden zu schaffen
der jede Möglichkeit zu Nichte machen
wird 2024 freie Wahlen in Venezuela
abzuhalten die Frage ist nur wie weit
Maduro gehen wird um diese
innenpolitischen Ziele zu erreichen denn
er wäre nicht der erste der deswegen
einen Krieg vom Zaun bricht und deswegen
bleiben wir an diesem Thema dran und
werden euch über alle Hintergründe und
geopolitischen Implikationen auf dem
Laufenden halten vergesst daher bitte
nicht das Abo und glückchen um keines
unserer Videos zu verpassen und bis
dahin seid ihr mit eurer Meinung an der
Reihe wusstet ihr von diesem Konflikt
zwischen Venezuela und Guyana wart ihr
euch des Ressourcenreichtums dieser
beiden Länder bewusst glaubt ihr dass
carakas es wagen würde in sein
Nachbarland einzumarschieren und wie
könnte der Konflikt am Ende gelöst
werden wird es eventuell doch freie
Wahlen in Venezuela geben können wie
immer sind auch eure Kommentare zu
diesem Thema schon hochgradig gespannt
ich hoffe dass euch dies Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht auch was dabei
gelernt habt falls ja gibt uns bitte ein
Like Teil mit euren Freunden und
diskutiert es mit ihnen natürlich freuen
wir uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende
von euch mit uns h dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung un dem Video macht's
gut und bis
[Musik]
bald